this episode of congratulations the
podcast is brought to you by the cash
app I don't know if you've seen this but
the cash app has done something amazing
they've introduced this cash card that
looks like this and it's a new black
debit card and you can design yourself
you could design it yourself via the app
and it's very cool the cash card allows
you to use cash that you keep in your
app anywhere you want so now that you
have the cash app which is the best way
to pay back plus the all-new cash card
you're all set I'll talk more about this
later on in the show so download the
free cash app for iOS or Android now hey
what's up my babies is Chris D'Elia it's
congratulations episode 38 and that's 38
that's that's probably 38 more episodes
than I thought I'd ever have and we
haven't even been doing it for a year
and we're taking you know we're taking
off we're rocket we're sky rocketing
well rocketing with rocket we're a
rocket and we're shooting up you know
and occasionally we go up and up and up
and then you know dip a little bit but
then that's because you know people have
day days where they got to work and they
can't listen to the podcast and our
numbers are going up those steadily
going up so that's what's up
blocked a few people for being Kudus the
past week been really been really hmm
talking about this Wendi's thing online
about how Wendy's made this thing called
saw some sauce or something saw some
sauce tell people to ban that bit you
know they're bent they're gone they're
gone dude if they ever wanted to pay
money and and do a [ __ ] sponsor here
they can't do because there first of all
the sauce is not awesome and second of
all it's free conch you can eat that
sauce but it's [ __ ] terrible and it
will give you cancer okay it will give
you cancer here's the deal if you eat
that
every day you'll get cancer that's what
it should be
if you eat fast food every day you will
get cancer period siga it was nice
knowing ya
you got all tumor DUP so don't eat fast
food that much cuz you'll get cancer and
that's just the truth
select smokin or standing near a power
plant speaking of which I was watching
The Incredible Hulk with Edie Edie
Norton right
I love how eid norton was into
incredible to hoax or whatever and then
all of a sudden it was gonna be Mark
Ruffalo and that's how you know Ed
Norton is a [ __ ] he's got to be a
piece of [ __ ] I don't know for real if
he is or not but like if you're in two
of the movies then one made a sequel and
then the Avengers comes out and they're
like never mind we're gonna get Mark
Ruffalo you got to be hard to work with
you gotta be right but I saw Ed Norton
in primal fear recently I seen it
already but he's so good in that movie I
mean he's good he's a good actor but I
I'm also there was Erik Bona was the
Hulk - how many guys are gonna play the
[ __ ] Hulk in the bin in the past
eight years I feel like it's gonna be
pretty soon it's gonna be there's gonna
be a new like Hulk movie and it's gonna
be starring Greg Kinnear or something or
some young [ __ ] you know when they do
that [ __ ] it's so annoying when they
make the superhero movies and then the
guys get too old and then they pick an
eight year old they're like but this is
what this is Batman before he was Batman
and then the guys like hey I'm Batman
I got T I want TT in my pants I want TT
and it's like starring Charlie like it's
just he's so young he doesn't have a
last name just like I don't even know
what the last name is because they were
like hey you know when you're a young
kid your mom's like what's your full
name and you're like okay Chris D'Elia
and how old are you and you're like this
many that's the Batman that's a new
Batman movie coming that's Batman
origins we talked about origins already
in this [ __ ] story in this podcast
and it's uh it's annoying origin stories
they
made a [ __ ] winnie-the-pooh origin
story or some [ __ ] like really a [ __ ]
teddy bear Oh had that teddy bear come
to be doesn't matter teddy bear it
barely matters that a big Green Giant
has an origin story although they didn't
make the Hulk well every I did every
story is always well I think that's what
the new spider-man movie did though I'm
not sure about the spider-man movie the
new one but I feel like it didn't
finally mid they made a movie where it
didn't [ __ ] have to explain what the
[ __ ] happened I didn't say so I
literally don't know what I'm talking
about but um but there were so many
there was every Batman movie was about
like how he became Batman and then
[ __ ] every spider-man was about how
he became spider-man and then [ __ ]
Thor by the way the new Ragnarok the
thor ragnarok poster looks like [ __ ]
oh wait this is what I want to talk
about actually the Thor Ragnarok is at
Ragnarok by the way what the [ __ ] is
Ragnarok just don't put syllables
together and make it couldn't look more
like a [ __ ] hippie made that poster
where it was just like there's so it's
there's so many colours it looks
it actually looks so Asian the thor
ragnarok poster looks like a [ __ ]
twelve-year-old asian made it and it
looks buddhist as [ __ ] too but why does
thor have short hair in this one oh I
would love it if [ __ ] Chris Hemsworth
was like mmm
not at this time we're not doing
extensions this time you want to [ __ ]
come up with a movie we're doing it this
way but you got to see
so the thor ragnarok poster is I mean
it's pretty wild whatever it's the
movies gonna make a good jillion dollars
anyway you got to see the [ __ ] poster
of the new Black Panther poem thing
there's 50 people on it like just put
the guy on it and that's fine and put
Michael B Jordan on it that's fine too
who's but the poster of
what's the guy's name [ __ ] the [ __ ]
a guy's name in the Black Panther movie
I feel like it's placed straight-up
racist I don't even know his name
Chadwick Chadwick Boseman what the [ __ ]
is Chadwick um
chad is that what everybody is that what
chat is short for you people calm chat I
guess Michael B Jordan dude it look at
it look on Chadwick Boseman 's Instagram
it's got the first it's got the new
poster for the Black Panther poster
there's [ __ ] straight-up 75 people on
the poster and Chadwick Boseman is on
the top and then it's Michael look at it
why there's I swear to god there's so
many people in there there's a guy with
three lines in the movie on the poster
there's an extra on the poster and the
actor was like oh [ __ ] I get to be on
the poster dude and I get it because it
couldn't just been Chadwick Boseman
because Michael B Jordan is so is so big
he's probably a bigger star than
Chadwick right but so Michael B Jordan
was like well they were like well we
gotta put him on the poster and then we
have to put a female on the poster we're
gonna have to dudes because not a
two-hander it's not like it's two people
it's about the one Black Panther right
so then they put a female on the poster
and then they were like well and then
they put like and then they were like
well there's lots of black people on the
poster we should partner one white
person a poster so white people goes
through the movie and then they were
just like got so carried away and some
executive was like well let's just put
why don't we just put we put him on it
too and be like and then they look later
on they were like didn't he just do
craft service didn't he just put i swear
to god that guy just came he was like
there for a week and just kind of gaffed
and he's on the poster it too many
people on the poster somebody Photoshop
a poster where there's [ __ ] for real
75 different people on the Black Panther
poster that will be [ __ ] hilarious I
would love to see it superhero movies
are so serious dude and also I don't
know so
here's the people in the movie chadwick
boseman Michael B Jordan Lupita Nyong'o
nakiye Danai gurira oh oh yay I mean
don't know from Salem right of course
Forest Whitaker who is in him is one of
the greatest actors that you can never
understand I swear to God thank I didn't
know ever what Forest Whitaker was ever
saying in movies until TiVo came out or
you could have subtitles on Netflix I
think even subtitles on Netflix
sometimes I run for do we do Forest
Whitaker movies and then they
straight-up just have question marks on
the bottom because they don't even know
what he says he'll be like that's a mana
wit song in a man and you're like uh
just question marks of course Andy
Serkis is in Black Panther you know Andy
Serkis first of all last name s Russian
is that even Russian if it is it is if
it isn't it is but Andy Serkis is always
the [ __ ] guy who plays like the
monkey or the elf or some [ __ ] that
those words like not him but it's him
it's like the it's like such a good job
because if you don't want to be famous
you you kind of like he's one of the BEA
he's in the biggest blockbusters of all
time but he plays like he'll literally
play like the demon that you don't
recognize or a [ __ ] elf or like like
in in this movie Black Panther there's
no way he [ __ ] shows his face there's
a pipe plays like a [ __ ] chair or
some [ __ ] one day he'll play a chair for
real and they'll be like oh yeah we got
Andy's here and they'll just sit in a
squat position and they'll put him on
against a green screen and then [ __ ]
the other more famous guy will just sit
on him during the scene and they'll be
like and people and [ __ ] idiot people
in Hollywood will be like oh my god dude
he was so good as the chair did you see
he just the way he did and they always
do but the behind the scenes on HBO
you know how HBO will have like these
[ __ ] 30-minute things where it's like
a first look [ __ ] the CUDA Chronicles
and it'll be like well Andy Serkis
played a chair and it was just amazing
it's amazing when you get an actor that
can just
really kind of understand the mannerisms
of a chair and you see him just doing a
squat position and he's just like I'm
throwing it on my chair come sit on me
it just is annoying like that kind of
[ __ ] is annoying like he's great at what
he does obviously like [ __ ] you know
you can't just get Javier Bardem to just
play a [ __ ] monkey he obviously can't
do that because he wouldn't be as good
as andy serkis andy serkis studies the
[ __ ] you know I don't know if he lived
with monkeys or whatever but like you
can't just get some actor like Harrison
Ford playing a monkey it would be you be
able to be [ __ ] not as good but like
it drives me nuts that people are like
it you know what's the same thing I I
saw this I turn on this movie the other
day on Hulu it wasn't a Hulu original or
anything but it was called cash with a
[ __ ] s that's a dollar sign of course
of course because he could they couldn't
let that fly some [ __ ] [ __ ] was
like oh do wait make the s that dollar
sign and they were like oh of course and
it's a French movie and by the way it's
the most French movie of all time if you
watch this movie cash you watch the
first [ __ ] 10 minutes of this movie
it's the most for it's not that one it's
the most French movie of all time the
guy from the artist is in it it's that
no it's not that one the guy from the
artist is in it but this is why I
started talking about it so anyway
that's it dude
first of all the guy Jean d'Azur
what did the [ __ ] is his name so French
sick goddamn handsome he's so handsome
and he's [ __ ] in this movie and in
the movie it's the most French the first
ten minutes of although I turned it off
because it was too French I was
literally I was like uh after the fact
of the first ten minutes I was online
trying to shop for a [ __ ] easel
that's how French it was so I had to
like turn out I was like they have to
tend this movie off and so in the first
beginning of the movie first of all it's
about a heist which is this French but
he is literally watching this girl leave
someplace and he's talking to little
kids and these little kids are like hey
how come you always win and then he says
something to the little kids like in
French it's
French movie and he says because you're
a loser like so French to [ __ ] be
like so straight up with a kid and be
like that's because you had a lose lu5
they held and he leaves and smirks of
course he sir marks the most French [ __ ]
of all time and say handsome you got to
see this guy and he ain't no he smells
[ __ ] terrible too
nothing is more French than looking so
handsome on screen and in real life
having a big head and being and smell so
bad and that by having a bed that's way
too big nothing is more French than
being so handsome on screen that you see
the guy in real life and he's [ __ ]
five foot nine and his head is [ __ ]
so big and he's got broad his [ __ ]
shoulders and it's like weird and you're
like I didn't know he's gonna be so
stocky and he smells so bad that that's
the most French thing of all time
so now this guy I mean he's so handsome
it's so funny dude look look at his
eyebrow dude right win that one
and so and so so he leaves the kids and
goes and looks at this girl and then he
sees this girl sit down in like a hair
salon leaves goes to a [ __ ] flower
place and she said and the guys like and
he's like I want some of these flowers
and the guys like what flower how many
do you want and of course he says all of
them cuz that's written and then he has
the guys bring [ __ ] all of the
flowers into the salon to the girl
alright now here's the French as part of
all time now she's looking around like
what the heck who did this and she looks
out the window she's this handsome guy
on a [ __ ] trolley and he smirks it
her and the trolley takes off and drives
away
he Oh so French and you know she's
thinking wow his head's big in real life
good thing he's far away so I can't
smell him dude it's it's he calls a kid
a loser by 700 flowers for a [ __ ]
girl he doesn't know gets in a trolley
leaves she sees him and smirks and flow
and and leaves and you know oh and then
he pickpockets somebody by the way could
it be
French could it be more French and he
does it in a clever way
he doesn't just bump in women
pickpockets um he [ __ ] does it in the
most clever way and genre knows in the
movie and so is she Aaron Hinda sore
whatever the [ __ ] his name is the most
French guy is Francois brilliant oh you
couldn't look more French than Francois
barely and you couldn't look more French
I thought that picture oh that's the guy
from isn't he and uh I think he's from
the transporter - no I don't know anyway
yeah I think he's the detective in their
transporter right there that picture
where he's laughing right there is that
him yeah there right there was when
somebody tried to say I'm actually more
French than you let's show it on the
video podcast that picture and then they
and they went because he was he's like
there's no way and someone snapped that
photo so yeah so it's literally the most
French first ten minutes of any movie
ever and the guy so the guy is so
handsome like if I had to [ __ ] somebody
I'd do I'd [ __ ] him I guess a guy you
know and I would make love I would be
like man I would even even though I'm
not gay and I don't want to be having
sex with him I'd still be like man I'm
so lucky that I got to have sex with him
and I would be holding his big-ass head
and I would be like but I feel like he
smells bad I'm so so lucky so so and
then so what I was talking about the
Andy Serkis thing where people like blow
up how it goody is that [ __ ] be in a
monkey okay great yeah he's good but
like let's not let's not like I swear
he's like I swear like for about two or
three years in there he's been like at
the Academy's been like maybe we should
nominate him and it's like get the [ __ ]
out of here you know so this is why I
started talking about this movie cash
because the lead got the lead guy in
cash was as handsome is the in the
artist that gotten that won best picture
right now here's the deal in 2008 or
whenever it came out it was a silent
movie
now you can win Best Picture
if you're a silent film period unless
you're 1920 but it was like 2008 this
[ __ ] movie came out and took all
these protect now I'm not saying it's a
bad movie I watched the whole thing and
it well you know what it was it was good
for a silent movie and it was a fine
movie okay you know what I kept thinking
in that movie while I was watching it
why is no one talking cuz it's 2008 or
whatever year it was that came out and
why have my producer not told me yet one
firearm but like super tensest was in
black and white made it 2011 now it was
fun it was good whatever but come on
guys hey we're past it you can't [ __ ]
make a silent film in 2011 and [ __ ]
win Best Picture
unless you're being voted on by kudus
because you're getting all mixed up in
the sauce and you're [ __ ] totally
buying into it you pretentious fuckos
it's so pretentious
there's [ __ ] out there playing
people with cancer crying and [ __ ]
there's out guys out there doing accents
dead-on [ __ ] you know what I mean
and then this guy this guy gets an did
he win Best Actor he won Best Actor for
what blinking he got Best Actor for
smiling dude here's how you know it
didn't deserve Best Picture or he didn't
deserve Best Actor because he didn't do
any other [ __ ] movies worth the damn
afterwards Best Picture
that's Actor Best Director Best Original
Music score that's the only one that
should have got it because that's all
there was
Best Supporting Actor actress these are
all the nominees or winners winners our
Best Picture Best Actor Best Director
lick my [ __ ]
Oh Best Original s one nominee for Best
Original Screenplay
interior guy walks in handsome as [ __ ]
he's smiling
girl walks in he blinks three times he
goes and picks up a piece of coffee and
then gives her some coffee she drinks it
she smiles it's so silent fade out hey
go [ __ ] yourself okay
nominated for Best Screenplay hey [ __ ]
yourself okay if I was not if I wrote a
[ __ ] silent but first of all how long
was that script you know how long that
script was I guarantee was 55 pages it
should be 420 page of scripts but when
action happens it takes up so much
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] oh my god
it dude how about how if this movie came
out in 1930 it probably would even got
nominated because it would probably
wasn't even a good silent movie you know
what's also annoying about it is it
takes place when silent movies were made
like if you want to [ __ ] really do it
for real silent movie do it now
do one with the rock and have [ __ ]
like buildings blowing up and [ __ ] and
demons running around make a southern
film about that oh you had to [ __ ] go
back to the 20s and make a [ __ ] you
had to make a period piece a silent
movie come on bro [ __ ] out of here with
the artist [ __ ] the whole thing is
pretentious it's called the artist
so much [ __ ] so much good as [ __ ] bro
that's why I'm wearing this shirt to let
these [ __ ] know ye code we're
making more ku t-shirts with a different
design to beyond the wear beyond the
wear be on the lookout not wear
why would I said that why the [ __ ] would
I say that is it because I hate too much
ass awesome sauce and now I have a brain
cancer um my buddy asked me he's like
how come you're in how do you keep in
shape and and I was like well I just
work out really hard I am conscious
about what I eat I mean he's like you
don't drink soda I was like nah I was
like why he do he said yeah I said how
many coke he said you know how many
cokes I had yesterday I said how many he
said nine hey man that's why I don't
drink nine sodas he's not even fat he's
just like beggar I guess I don't know
but uh he's yeah I don't know man don't
drink nine cokes God not the way that
corporations do this [ __ ] and and they
try to pump what I stopped drinking
coca-cola and anything like that I don't
drink it anymore and the reason why I
stopped is because I was um I watched
his documentary Forks Over knives and I
and then I started reading about it
because I was interested in the in the
in the [ __ ] and I read this article
about like why it was like against
coca-cola and they were saying something
about how they were at this meeting
where the head of coke was there or
something like that and he was like
we're not trying to figure out how to
sell more coke to people who drunk don't
drink coke we're trying to figure out
how to put more coke coca-cola into
people and that was when I thought wow
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up and then I
stopped drinking coke right after I read
that interview we're trying to put more
coke into people that might not be a
direct quote but it was something like
that like we want more coke in the
people that already drink coke like yo
what are we [ __ ] cars
with gasoline like that's so gross so I
stopped drinking coca-cola because it
will kill you
put down your [ __ ] soda dude pick up
some water
cuz you're gonna die how about when
people do [ __ ] like smoke cigarettes and
they're like hey you're gonna die anyway
huh huh hey man like did you know what
they think they think they're secretly
in like an action mystery weather just
like hey man something's gonna kill you
anyway catch you later
I'm gonna go back into my [ __ ] desk
job you're not a detective [ __ ]
you're not [ __ ] trying to case some
murder something's gonna kill you anyway
whatever doesn't kill you makes you
stronger no it doesn't you can break
your leg and then have a [ __ ] bad leg
and then you're a you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah hey man doesn't matter
well something out there Kenya yeah you
can get hit by a car okay but still eat
broccoli oh you can get killed you can
get run over you can get attacked by a
mountain lion but still eat kale hey you
can get [ __ ] murdered but still don't
eat so many twists lers you know like
don't be so [ __ ] hard-headed and this
is coming from me all right here we go
don't be so hard-headed and don't eat so
many Twizzlers lifts lifts knows that
their drivers are what keep them moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure their drivers are happy on every
trip it's a simple formula happy drivers
make happy passengers maybe that's why I
like 9 out of 10 lift rides get a
perfect five-star rating so you can earn
hundreds of dollars a week if you work
for
plus tips you want to earn more money
drive more it's easy you give yourself a
race that's how you do it you keep a
hundred percent of the tips they don't
go to anyone else and they add up fast
drivers have been paid over two hundred
million dollars since the feature was
first introduced that's a lot of money
you know many shirts you can buy with
that lift has even taken the guesswork
out of pickups the new amp device uses
color coding to help passengers to find
the driving I see that and when I see
those things go around and get jealous
that I'm not in those cars because
they're lit up I go to lift calm /
Congrats today and you can get a $500
new driver bonus that's lift calm /
Congrats lift calm / Congrats limited
time only terms apply so join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better lift
stamps.com these days you can get
practically everything on demand like
our podcast listen whenever you want
when it's convenient for you so why are
you still using why are you going let me
ask you a question why are you going to
the post office and dealing with their
limited hours what if you want to do
something at 3 a.m. you can go and get
posted on demand with stamps calm stamps
calm anything you can do at the post
office you can do right now from your
desk with stamps calm you listening to
this podcast 2 a.m. you night owl do it
by imprint official us posted postage
for any letter or package using your own
computer and printer and unlike the
postage office stamps calm never closes
right now use the word congrats for this
special offer four week trial includes
postage and a digital scale don't wait
go to stamps calm before you do anything
else click on the radio microphone at
the top right of the homepage and type
in congrats that stamp calm stamps calm
click the microphone enter congrats
stamps calm never go to the post office
again how about that though for real man
going to the post office what going to
the post office huh oh oh I forgot it's
oh I forgot it's when we thought Oh Jay
was still a good guy going to the post
office imagine waiting in line for
anything go online go online find you're
waiting in line to have to use your
internet you know you know what I want
to give a shout out to for real is you
know you know what I want to what I want
to tell you makes me BRM when guys get
upset when guys talk about when guys
talk [ __ ] about fake boobs that's what I
want to talk about right now when guys
are like nah not for me man man I'm an
all natural kind of guy yo dude you got
a midbrain
you're a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] okay that's
what charged just like me
we're dumb [ __ ] we're guys you see a
red car drive by you look at it cuz you
got a lizard brain in there somewhere
that's our midbrain reacting telling us
to [ __ ] see that red car okay so now
I'm talking about there's bad fake boobs
out there of course there's botched jobs
you've seen botched you seen dr. Beverly
Hills one of those [ __ ] stupid as
[ __ ] he shows our [ __ ] those shows II
you know with an exclamation point
inu 'he's you know but when guys act
like they're too good for like chicks
with fake boobs shut up dude you know
what that means to me you haven't seen
enough boobs you loser dude there
really good fake boob jobs out there and
they're fun to play with man
and yeah look I like the natural look to
dude I'm not downplaying that I think
it's amazing but [ __ ] that dude man dude
dude's always trying to act holier than
thou and [ __ ] nah man uh I'd rather
[ __ ] a girl be all natural that guy's
always that guy's just trying to get
into the good graces of girls to try and
sneak in the side door and get some
[ __ ] that's what he's trying to do
you're [ __ ] trying to sneak in the
side door and get some [ __ ] bro I'll
[ __ ] get bunk turn around and [ __ ]
step out back up a little bit dunk get
CUDA and I'm just gonna give you a
little bit PAP that's just a little bit
of a [ __ ] you know
right jab a left jab and a right hook
that's just it's not a full combo but
dude step the [ __ ] out turn round good
gunk
you gota come on bro stop trying to
[ __ ] sneak in the side door and get
some [ __ ] hit it straight on dude you
can't I get it you got to use what you
can get to get like laid and [ __ ] but
like it's supposed to be hard to meet a
girl and [ __ ] fall in love and and
and make love it's supposed to be hard
we're supposed to [ __ ] as much as we're
supposed to [ __ ] guys like [ __ ] who
try to sneak in the side row and then
got four big guys like [ __ ] Bill
Cosby who literally rape its if you're
ruining the world it's supposed to be as
hard as it is you're not supposed to
sneak in the side door or take what you
want you're supposed to meet a lovely
lady hope it fits it off and you're not
supposed to [ __ ] say [ __ ] like
that now for me man
oh I'd never do that to you oh shut up
these [ __ ] white knights you know
guys drive me nuts when they try to act
holier than thou in front of a girl just
to try and [ __ ] sidestep the friend
the guy who has the girlfriend that's
like always trying to this is like nah
she's just a friend man that like like
he wouldn't [ __ ] drop his pants
faster than Donald Trump fires a new guy
if he was going to like if the girl
wanted to have sex how about that how
about those guys how about those guys
how about those guys dude those guys
yeah she's you know we go hiking and all
that [ __ ]
oh yeah you kiss her oh no she's just a
friend oh you a hiking modern [ __ ] yeah
how many times you go hiking by yourself
no she actually introduced me to hiking
oh you've never been hiking before oh no
no oh but you like it yeah oh yeah do it
I love it that's why now we go oh really
since you met her have you ever gone
alone no no no it's like our thing oh
cool hey man you're a [ __ ] what are you
doing
you're dating a girl without loving her
you're dating a girl without lying with
her you know and you can say oh [ __ ]
yeah but you don't you know there are oh
well I do I do that though Chris and
it's cool all right cool you know what
yeah there's rare exceptions I guess
sure but you know who you are guys and
you know what you're doing and you won't
admit it
and I get it but you know what you're
doing and I know what you're doing and
guess what the girl knows what you're
doing too
pack it up pack it up dude
go on a trip see you go on a trip say
yeah you know it's so hard to talk about
this [ __ ] without seeming like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] but it's just nice it is it's a
real thing you know it's a real [ __ ]
thing and it sucks because it's all like
oh yeah but you know guys I'm not saying
guys can't be friends with chicks I'm
friends with a lot of girls man
they're awesome Whitney Cummings is my
[ __ ] best friend we work together all
the time never touched her you know
respect the [ __ ] out of her but it's so
annoying that like guys do this [ __ ] man
anyway uh but yeah guys who [ __ ] say
that like Oh any guy who says that they
don't like fake boobs would gladly date
a guy with fake boobs we'll just put it
our leader girl with fake boobs and put
it that way
gladly gladly gladly any guy who says oh
I don't know I'm not into fake boobs but
gladly gladly gladly date a girl with
fake boobs and come real hard when they
have sex so don't play me like that dude
if you're gonna stand and look at me and
say I'm not into fake boobs you're gonna
[ __ ] play me like that dude look in
my eyes and say that [ __ ] and watch me
[ __ ] imagine eating your face bro
that's how it is man that's what I do
when somebody says some [ __ ] good
dumb [ __ ] like that dude
why are you in the room right now when
you should be stepping out and dunk and
then I'll open the door your nose better
be facing the same direction so I could
place myself inside you cuz you don't
want me to
I you know whatever this is a good one
for a video podcast cuz I'm you know how
about [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein now Jesus
Christ I know I talked about him last
time but I there's a new one about Angie
Everhart where he like broke into her
room at on a boat and like masturbated
in front of her like what the [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] ugly troll
dude it's supposed to be hard to get
laid
it's supposed to be hard to get laid
it's supposed to be hard to have an
orgasm in the presence of a woman so you
don't get to break into her bedroom and
masturbate in front of her you [ __ ]
troglodyte dork and everyone in
Hollywood was apologizing for him until
the [ __ ] recently and then now that oh I
didn't know you did no I never [ __ ]
met the guy I knew
but don't [ __ ] roust him from the
Academy and then leave all the other
[ __ ] that are in the Academy
there's [ __ ] isn't Bill Cosby
still in the [ __ ] Academy what you
doing
[ __ ] all that hypocritical [ __ ] man and
then you're gonna have all those people
in the Academy and nominate the artist
for Best Original Screenplay that right
there
makes me want to move to Mars huh
you [ __ ] up the game bro you [ __ ] up the
game in a very silly way and I
understand I understand that it's a real
bad bad evil thing to [ __ ] grope
women and [ __ ] do all that [ __ ] and
masturbate in front of them
you're a [ __ ] horrible piece of [ __ ]
and you're [ __ ] up the game in a
silly way you're [ __ ] up the game
dude keep your [ __ ] dick in your
pants I read this Facebook post the
other day about my buddy and he was like
I think that a good idea would be asking
always beforehand can I kiss you and I
was like I don't know if that's the
answer that that's complete boner
removal and wetness reduction
I mean may i kiss you huh bro no no you
can't I wish I could be a girl in that
situation so I could be like so I could
laugh so hard for 25 minutes and wipe
the tears as I'm laughing because this
[ __ ] guy said this and it's not the
1600s in Great Britain may i kiss here
imagine taking a girl imagine being at a
bar or just like the sheer [ __ ]
desert dryness of can I kiss you what
oh sure betta I mean case-by-case sure
asking is fine but every time boner
removal put your [ __ ] penis in a
duffel bag come on dude there's a middle
let's not let this time [ __ ] up so hard
in the other direction you understand
what I'm saying let's not [ __ ] it up so
hard in the other direction right you
understand
saying like let's not now lock all of
our dicks up and just be like is it okay
if I place my lips around the same
vicinity as yours let's not [ __ ] up that
hard let's recognize what we're doing
wrong without letting the pendulum swing
all the other way and having it be like
do you mind if I unzip my mouth and in
and show you my tongue you know let's
not create a world where masculinity
doesn't exist how about that how about
that because guys sometimes you need
guys to do some basic [ __ ] like help
[ __ ] pick up a goddamn desk or a
refrigerator and that's okay but man
let's not let the pendulum swing that's
that's see that's what happens you know
like all these all these me two stories
are coming out and they're they're
[ __ ] horrible you know with the
hashtag on and blowing up and about how
a guy grabbed me and how a guy [ __ ]
exposed himself to me and a guy you know
use sexual harassment at work and all
that shit's horrible it's unacceptable
and then there are these girls that just
want to be on the thing and make up
[ __ ] stories and that's bad - it's
like misfile 'im the actual problem and
then [ __ ] deal with it
it's so hard
talk about this without seeming like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm trying I just I
just I I hate that kind of [ __ ] I
hate that kind of guy that [ __ ] is
like that as we all should and they
should be taking dealt with a lot of
them should be in jail and then also
that's the problem
but the problem isn't rectified by a guy
being like uh is it okay if I wear a
short sleeve shirt or some [ __ ] I
don't mean to you know I just like III
saw a story that some girl was had a
meet to thing on and she was like yeah
my agent dropped me because I wouldn't
go on an audition and say a sexual line
in an audition for a commercial and I'm
like ah she was like yeah so me too and
I'm like ah or you know what like you
you just wouldn't go on and on you
wouldn't set you wouldn't you you
wouldn't go on an audition like that's
different and I get it there's a scale
and but like you know I wouldn't [ __ ]
do certain auditions and that's okay too
you don't have to do those auditions but
it wasn't like sort it's all about this
without seeming like a [ __ ] don't
care I do care but it's just like don't
jump on the bandwagon it disrespects
people who have that actual thing that
happened in their life because that's
terrible anyway
anyway uh it's horri yeah it's horrible
it's horrible when I love how you could
do it like this if I can talk about the
oldest [ __ ] that's so hot bad in the
world and then just be like square cash
everyone is switching to the cash app
because it's the best way to pay people
back friends family co-workers anyone
really you got to send receive money
it's totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly to
your bank account in seconds here's how
it works
download the square cash app and it's
better than the other guys but you
download the square cash cab it links to
your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment they get a
notification that they've just received
money that's it no gimmicks it's not a
social network and you don't need to
list what it's for I hate that so let's
talk about the new cash card it's a new
black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app and the cash card
allows you to use the cash that you keep
in the app anywhere you want you'll get
a notification for all the payments made
with the card directly via the cash app
you can laser at your card and
personalize it and it will be delivered
directly to you for free it's cool you
signature on there you know it's awesome
the cash app team is constantly building
awesome new features so what are you
doing using the other guys get the cash
up today download the free cash app for
iOS or Android now wink now you guys
know if you're a fan of mine or if you
listen to this podcast or you're in my
cult you know that I'm not a drinker but
that doesn't mean I don't like to
entertain when my guests can have great
wine and I don't have to worry about
what I'm buying I'm happy my guests are
happy and I'm happy now let me tell you
about this company called wink
they give you access to exceptional
wines from around the world just go to
try wink calm spelled TR ywi and see
calm take a brief pallet profile quiz
and wink will recommend distinct and
interesting wines actually customized to
your palate to be shipped directly to
your door every month none of your time
is wasted fitting in a run to the store
or on your way home from work or on your
way to an event or gathering it saves
time and you don't have to guess what
you like is they'll help you out wink
bases the ones that send they base the
wines that they send
to your taste preferences what I'm
trying to say no membership fees skip
any month cancel anytime 100%
satisfaction guarantee and right now
wink is offering my listeners $20 off
your first order when you go to try wink
calm / Congrats that's tri wink spelled
T ry winc comm / Congrats and get 20% or
$20 off $20 off your first order now tri
wink com / Congrats so yeah not right
now
[Music]
[Laughter]
video podcasts you got to watch it if
you don't watch a video you missing out
a little bit you know putting a mister I
saw I was talking about fake boobs it's
funny though the coz another thing that
made me think about while I was talking
about it is uh like you know what I
don't understand is like I like I like
sex like straight-up sex when whenever
I'm like with a girl and she's like
do you've any fetishes like if we've
been dating for a bit I'm like I like I
don't you know like I'm just
I like sex it's fine you get to come
feels good you know it's not like you're
[ __ ] it's not like quinoa
we have to cook it differently and [ __ ]
and you're like I am bored of it maybe
I'll put some [ __ ] cumin in it or
whatever the [ __ ] it's not chicken oh
I've been eating barbeque let me try to
put some lemon [ __ ] let me put a
reduction sauce on it it's sex dude you
get to calm so like when people are like
what's your fetish I'm like I don't have
always feel like when a girl asked me
what's a fetish that they have one so I
gotta be like oh I like I like to what I
have sex while we're watching
documentaries but like I don't the
coming part is fine I got a buddy that's
into feet and I know that's like a big
one but like like you know the
see porn videos where some guys like
literally like jerk off on feet huh I
got a question
since when do feet have boobs on them
like what is up they also use feet to
jerk off their dicks doesn't feel good
you know why there's no thumbs on feet
you can't grip anything maybe Andy
Serkis could do it he's played [ __ ]
Apes dude you know Andy Serkis could
jerk you off with his feet in front of a
green screen
[ __ ] yeah do it that's how he gets jobs
I could do it I could shake you off I'm
basically an ape how [ __ ] how much
are are like producers and executives
thanking their lucky stars that the guy
who's best at that isn't a black guy by
the way like they could therefore have
that guy be a black guy to [ __ ] do
the green screen in the [ __ ] and be
an ape and a Planet of the Apes
that's [ __ ] they're like thank God
thank God he's white oh my god that's
[ __ ] funny actually to think about
but the but yeah Andy Serkis could jerk
the [ __ ] off of your feet with a dick
with his feet because he's [ __ ] yeah
I don't understand it also looks so
uneventful - what in the porns like I've
seen him because it's because of the
curiosity when a guy like has an orgasm
and then like expels on the girls feet
it's always like so uneventful it's like
ah she's got to just wipe her feet off
now like she entered a [ __ ] Asian
person's house it's racist well no not
really I mean I always had to do that
when I was a kid and what any time I
walked into my Asian buddies house
they'd be like shoes off I guess it's a
respect thing I don't really actually
don't know I'm such an idiot all right
well we're gonna we're gonna
do a new elder here we've got an elder
here that we're gonna announce we didn't
do one last week so it's been building
up and we appreciate all of the past
elders and you guys are still elders I
think we have about three or four pins
out there these pins are not for sale I
know you want them for sale I know some
of these these pins are [ __ ] awesome
to their little in there there there's
their [ __ ] metal and I wear mine I
represent and people want them to my
opener was trying to act like I don't
want a pin I don't want a pin because
I'm not on my own guy and then by the
end of the conversation he was like dude
how do I get a pin they're [ __ ]
awesome dude look at these of the video
podcasts they say elder on them and they
and they're [ __ ] nice and I put it on
you can put it on your you Kuta shirt
it's a Salesman we've got these elder
pins they are not for sale but they are
free if you go above and beyond
further congratulations Colt and how
much with the guy have trouble too with
it now I'm just trying to get the pin on
here on my your cutest shirt that is on
the website and just not it's not hard
it's me trying to just have trouble in
my small motor skills there we go
it's all right there and it looks and it
looks good doesn't it yeah looks good
doesn't it right there put it above the
put it right above the the tail of the
kuda and you get one these are not for
sale these are st. when you go above and
beyond
license kill I love nothing more than
infomercials ah nothing we've got a
shirt it's beautiful
we're giving him away how they do it
like that they do so much volume control
it's so [ __ ] hilarious we've got a
beautiful dresser for your bedroom we're
giving them away do you know what you
can buy with this amount of money
nothing practically nothing dude so
here's the new elder man we are
announcing the elder Amanda Coupole at
Amanda online now this girl is
constantly tweeting about the show I see
her all the time and she dressed up as I
think me or the podcast and went to like
some kind of convention where I'm sure
nobody knew who the [ __ ] she was being
but um you know people dressed up like
Iron Man and she showed up as [ __ ] me
I guess but she made the gargle song and
her profile picture is of her with the
the Chris D'Elia silhouette shirt on and
she's just always kind of promoting the
podcast and always chiming in and she's
made some other songs and some artwork
and [ __ ] and she's just a very big big
fan of the podcast and she is has gone
above and beyond for sure and now she is
an elder she's an elder and we will DM
you with the details to get your to get
you your pin to get you your pin your
steel your embossed pan and your tea
so Thank You Amanda Coupole and welcome
you're an elder so yeah
I'm loving it I'm loving it I'm loving
the guy I'm loving the support you guys
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm saying
you know when people
I'm just saying [ __ ] about their support
but I love it man you guys are [ __ ]
awesome let me go and look online I
saved some of these [ __ ] wait a
minute is this real Newt Gingrich what
he tweeted it is what the [ __ ] is he
drunk Newt Gingrich just tweeted today
wow yeah president to Trump was
remarkably stirred going in who is joint
press event with Senator McConnell his
grasp of the issues is very deep and
growing
I mean hey man proofread hey man
proofread these [ __ ] ninety year old
guys that think it's like they can tweet
hey just give the phone to someone else
and tell him what you want to say you
don't even know how to [ __ ] use an
iPhone you idiot you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] Newt Gingrich like is he trying
to be made fun of this [ __ ] guy uh
all right enough of that though that's
not what we're here for
[Music]
all right here it is hey guys it's time
for the most [ __ ] up Instagram post of
the week
all right here we go guys here we go
guys this was sent to me in my DMS
thanks for the most [ __ ] up Instagram
posts the week there's so many of them
dude this one is great though this is
the I want to punch this guy all up and
down the [ __ ] Avenue okay this is a
guy what should I say I should I should
say that what's in the picture at second
and this one he says even if the girls
left and right trying to get my
attention first of all already wrong
sentence wise even if the girls left and
right trying to get my attention I am in
my zone where I visualize my dreams and
my goals oh oh I mean come on dude even
if the girls let he meant is it to the
left and right are trying to get my
attention even if the gusts of foreign
first of all even if the girls left and
right trying to get are trying to get my
attention I am in my zone where I
visualize my dreams and my goals no
you're not dude no you're not guarantee
if the girls are hot you checking them
out you [ __ ] douche okay and here we
go but be aware : and as we talked
before never put a [ __ ] colon in your
Instagram caption it is not enough to
see your future head in the [ __ ] you
have to feel it and then you will awaken
the magic power and magical things will
happen what is this guy talking about
the boner when he obviously sees when
he's checking the girls out to his left
and right that's why I didn't get
distracted when I saw and felt that's
why I didn't get distracted and I saw
and felt in my visual a visualization my
first my last my everything the love of
my life
I am waiting for
don't even know what he's talking about
but as I woke up I thought [ __ ] it
meanwhile let's have some fun uh totally
going against what he just said and then
create your life live your dreams and
then this guy is in the picture on a
beach chair and in the background
there's a girl bent over with no bottom
on um fixing her towel I guess I guess
that's a girl quote unquote trying to
get his attention which it's definitely
not
she's just fixing some [ __ ] on her thing
and then in the foreground to his right
there is literally a closeup of [ __ ]
a girl's boobs
I guess it's maybe his girl or something
but it's like the the most gross not
that it's gross I mean their boobs they
look good but like gross attempt of
[ __ ] trying to like show boobs and
he's got his eyes closed
visualizing his future I guess I mean
this [ __ ] guy and he's verified and
one of the cool one of the [ __ ]
comments is I want a pair of boobs like
this exclamation point lol and want is
misspelled it says I want like well
what's up with this man proofread a
[ __ ] lazy can you be proofread Iowa
want boobs like this [ __ ] you Charlie
Brown's teacher
so many problems and I just got nervous
I'm going to [ __ ] Australia some guy
just commented on it hit it I'm going to
Australia in a few hours and a mine I'm
a little I'm a little you know not I
don't know nervous or like I'm up I'm
nervous is the right word but yeah
because of the [ __ ] and I got to get
there and be in a foreign country it's
been a long time since I've been in a
foreign country really Canada doesn't
really count even though it is
technically I'm going to Australia I'm
gonna do a bunch of shows there all
around and I can't wait man I can't wait
I'm anticipating it and you can go get
tickets there's a few tickets left
there's a few tickets left on Chris
D'Elia calm but so I will be there and I
I say yeah Perth Perth Brisbane Adelaide
Melbourne and Sydney and I didn't know
the continent was so big like there's a
seven-hour flight I have to do in
Australia I didn't know that I thought
it was like his biggest [ __ ] Texas
I'm such an idiot you know they're like
people were bribed by the way if I see a
[ __ ] tarantula I'm out you understand
I'm out I'm going into the middle of a
[ __ ] square where there's a lot of
people and just just looking at the
ground if I see a [ __ ] hair dude how
about spiders have hair on it on them
get the [ __ ] out of here
what are you what are you a [ __ ] guy
what are you just somebody your spider
he's somebody you got hair hey if I
could put gel on you don't be an insect
you know
hey if I can put [ __ ] dippity-do on
your on you don't be an insect hey can I
spray Paul Mitchell on you then you're
not a spider you're a guy come on if I
can spray Paul Mitchell on the top of
you don't have eight legs have to sit
yeah so anyway I'll be there I'm also at
Irvine Irvine Ohio Columbus Ohio
San Jose those tickets are going quick
they might be gone I don't think they
are yet but they they they're going so
let's let's you know and don't be met
and weary stop restocking merchandise
you coulda [ __ ] we got new designs
coming we got and keep keep up with your
eldership but uh okay
so square cash have you switched yet
download the free square cash app and
design your cash card and get it for iOS
or Android now thanks for listening this
was episode [ __ ] 38 please spread the
word spread the gospel and you want a
pen
spread it rate and review the show tweet
me at congratulations pod or using the
hashtag hashtag congratulations pod
sorry we didn't game the system today
but I got a lot of [ __ ] to do I got to
get to Australia I gave you guys over an
hour anyway but I hope you're enjoying
the video episodes on YouTube video
episodes go up Thursdays at the latest
but even though the podcast is still
happening in Australia we're not going
to be able to do video podcast for two
weeks but we will are we gonna still put
it up with the thing will probably still
put it up on YouTube but it'll be the
artwork because I don't have the
lighting equipment and all that [ __ ] but
so so you can still listen to it on
YouTube but you won't be able to see me
and my dumb is [ __ ] [ __ ] face
numerous coming this week new merch
coming this week man on fire man on fire
watch it I keep
tweets new people watching the special
love it you can watch it re watch it
you're watching corrigible to my second
special and even you can watch white
male black comic which is my first
special that had the drunk girl [ __ ] on
it but I don't know a lot people seen
the drunk girls thing I don't know if a
lot of people have seen I mean I know
I'll know a lot he was in the drug scene
not seen the whole thing but you can
watch that on comedy central.com I think
and that's it
so thanks for listening you guys you
guys are all my babies remember when in
doubt you're my babies unless I block
yet because you did some [ __ ]
fucked-up thing with the cult because I
blocked a few people today not today but
this week and if i ban you from Wendy's
if i ban wendy's and go to win these
anytime you go to win these you get
blocked you banned for life it's free
conch but this is a cult take care of
babies thanks for listening see you soon
australia good i so annoying i did that
can't believe I did it I actually told
myself wasn't gonna do that but I did it
and I will absolutely do it when I get
to Australia on stage even though I know
that they're used to it and they don't
want me to do that and they hate when
communities do that but I'll still do it
I'll steal stop talking like this even
though it's annoying can't help myself
you are what you are and you got to
shake hands with yourself nice to meet
you I'm Chris I do those things
thank you very much don't be a kook
remember don't be a CUDA cuz if your
CUDA swatch are you don't want it [ __ ]
get a hit with a congratulations combo
how come all of a sudden it seems like I
took three shots of a gay girl okay take
care guys have a good one
[Music]